why do you think people get angry if you
start to discuss the basic truth that
boys and men face disadvantages
have you ever like had it where
you you spend the whole day out in town
you're walking around meeting friends
uh you know go on a date or go for
dinner and you get home and you've had
like food stuck between your teeth like
all day and it's like embarrassing
that is what I think is going on to the
left where they've badged themselves
quite literally bought the T-shirt about
their political ideas they badge
themselves and made their political
beliefs a fundamental part of who they
are some people's jobs are quite
literally dependent on certain political
philosophies and theories being true and
people will fight to the deaf to defend
them they'll look in the mirror and be
like oh oh no and they'll get angry at
everyone else not telling them and um I
feel like to overcome that identity
crisis where your community your friends
your job your lifestyle is all built
around a certain set of ideas if
something comes along that challenges
ideas it's a very difficult thing to
change it's like changing your skin you
can't really do it so which is why I try
not to identify with any political
movement neither MRI or feminism I try
to identify as George and George is a
constantly shifting selection of ideas
that I'm able to bring in take out as
and when I choose I'm not I'm not sort
of confined to my Community I know
there's a
I can't name him I can't remember who
said it but he was saying how
he's a psychologist and he talked about
how
um opinions don't necessarily exist in
someone's skull they exist in a
community it's like a shared belief that
Community has it's not like in someone's
mind so to change someone's mind you
either have to
disassociate yourself from that
community and lose friends family in a
way that I described earlier or you have
to change the mind of the entire
Community that's how you change
someone's mind and they're both
extremely hard things to do especially
when you're talking about very important
issues like Domestic and Sexual Violence
where sadly a huge amount of men and
women have personal experiences of that
and I generally I genuinely try to
understand like when people
um hate men I try to
understand what has happened to that
person for them to hate men so much when
I the same same principle applies and
look at Violent Men I don't just see
them as an end product of violence I
also I try to look into what have they
experienced so they've become this way I
truly believe that vast majority of
people are not born bad they've become
bad from their experiences and their
environment so I tried to ask challenge
people to ask themselves what sort of
Journey has that man been on and in the
same way the angry the angry people I
get in my comments and DMs I try to ask
like what have you experienced at the
hands of men
that has made you hate them so much and
I I try to apologize I'm sorry whatever
happened to you happened and I hope you
give a second chance but do you think
that most people who do hold those
beliefs have had first-hand personal
experience of being mistreated by men or
do you think that they see a culture
online that praises and raises up people
who push back against men as far as I
can see it's way more that mimetic I am
holding a belief that is currently
politically popular to hold which is to
I'm gonna stand up for the for the
dispossessed groups and I will ignore
information that suggests that a group
which isn't commonly seen as being
dispossessed actually might be therefore
men bad women good white bad black good
immigrant like good I just think that's
not easier we just if I had a
catchphrase it would be treat the issue
not the gender
like just look at the issue and if that
issue impacts 80 of women then 80 of the
benefits will go to women but we need to
look at the issue and like not see just
genders like if you look at domestic
violence like even in the most
conservative estimates one in three
victims is a man and yet there was
there's virtually nowhere for
um men to go so one in three victims at
one percent of refugees for men and like
that is not acceptable if I were to say
there was a group of survivors
who make up one in three victims and
they are systematically shut out of
refuges
people would lose their mind I tried
that all the time I'm like
um if you look at homeless people 90 of
deaths are of one type of group and
people get outraged upset and then you
reveal it's men and then again they're
they're confronted the same sense of
dissonance but um
I don't know it's just a lot it's just a
lot to overcome for some people and I
just don't think people are willing to
put in the effort like um
too much part of their life
and uh it's a shame it seems to me I I
learned this originally from Destiny but
I know that you kind of hold a similar
belief here which is that one of the
reasons that the right has dominated the
conversation with men so much is because
it's largely been evacuated by the land
that you don't get to tell men that they
are a problem or have a problem or need
to do better and not hold up
any potential role models for them to
step into you have to provide a positive
inspirational aspirational view for what
men could become and that has almost
exclusively been dominated by the right
and you know for every single person
every single person I don't care who you
are that says I have a problem with
Andrew Tate I have a problem with Jordan
Peterson okay
who do you suggest instead and I asked
the guy who you
um helped me prep for that debate that I
did in Qatar he I came out and they
played this video that was like a bunch
of
individuals famous individuals that
might be accused of being toxically
masculine in one form or another the
first one was milogianopolis and I was
like look if you've brought me here to
defend [__] Milo yiannopoulos I'm on
the wrong show yeah George Peterson Joe
Rogan the usual David Goggins the usual
crowd
and I was like okay
um I understand my interlocutor as I
understand that you have a problem with
the people that have just been held up
as potential role models for men
please tell me who you'd suggest instead
and it took 10 minutes in front of sorry
10 seconds in front of the live audience
of silence for him to say
my brother-in-law and I was like how
about somebody that we all know
it was I didn't mean to be mean but I
think it was a really important moment
that showed if you are from the left it
is really hard to find a positive image
for what men could and should be it's
just it goes back to what you said
before if women have a problem we say
what can we do to fix Society if men
have a problem we say what should men do
to fix themselves yeah yeah yeah you
know yeah quoting all my work now thank
you um
yeah I feel like I would say a better
example is like an example of a
masculine man like there's often an
example there's often certain Role
Models by left of men but I'd say they
don't I wouldn't say they're
traditionally masculine in in the way
they present themselves the strange
thing is that the the things that define
masculinity we do celebrate them but in
women
so when a woman is like confident and
loud and in your face and a go-getter
and a boss and you know
we love that and quite rightly so but if
you if you say oh yeah man confident to
go getting fierce in a fighter it's like
oh no we don't we don't like that toxic
toxic toxic and I I it's a shame because
we we just not don't seem to be
benefactors of the lessons of History
because this isn't the first time we've
pathologized agenda like I I part of me
thinks that toxic masculinity is just a
modern equivalent of female hysteria
where we take female distress and we
pathologize it as something to be
treated something that's wrong inside of
them and we subject them to this this
this these crazy sort of um experiments
to to fix the problem and we're doing
the same now we see masculinity as a
problem to be fixed and we're subjecting
men to the same bogus sort of corrective
therapies like the new masculinity
workshops sort of presented
new residential workshops are like
really really expensive uh workshops
that are about curing men of their
masculinity that are extraordinarily
expensive and entirely ineffective uh
they're done by this really just
instagramers who have done like a
six-week course on somewhere over and
that thinks they're a therapist a
therapeutic coach I think you have to
call themselves and it's basically about
correcting the problems of masculinity
it's the same thing we we subjected
women to like 50 or 60 years ago for the
so-called what's the female hysteria I
don't know the story about it so female
Hysteria
um it was basically a phenomenon that
looked at Women's distress and it
basically pathologized it as a problem
to be solved I think I mean I think it
was um part of his masturbation
therapies that were a cure and Pro or
anti pro pro yeah yeah masturbate more
and it'll get more more yeah I'm sure
I'm sure that there are many many women
that are like yeah very very hysterical
all the time actually I feel like I need
this treatment well I can't hurt to try
um
and you see this if you Google it you
see the same these black and white
photos of women in sort of core being
experimented on and it's it's horrific
and I feel like we pathologized female
distress instead of listening to it we
pathologized it as something that's
wrong in them and I I feel the same
about toxic masculinity I feel like the
frustrating thing is that the people
that disagree with me often don't
realize that the thing we disagree on is
semantics because I do I believe there
is
there are problems within men there were
Violent Men there were men are just very
aggressive competitive uh that are not
great at expressing their feelings those
are the problems I agree exist are
so-called toxic masculinity but I feel
like toxic masculinity is a term takes
the problem and stuffs into men's heads
and this is your problem and if you want
to solve it only you can solve it rather
than saying it as a societal issue so I
mean I would say toxic attitudes towards
men or toxic attitudes towards
masculinity which all of society is
guilty of perpetuating including women
and um
I feel like toxic masculinity just again
confines the problem to men's heads it
sort of takes a problem and puts them
puts them in into men's heads in a
slightly opposite patriarchy where
it sort of puts men inside of the
problem so patriarchy puts men inside of
the problem toxic masculinity puts the
problem inside of men and whatever it is
it's like this is your problem and like
for for a political movement that's all
about accountability it's like well
aren't we all accountable for what's
happening to men like what about the way
we value men or the sort of dating
standards that men are held to are they
not are they not part of it there's a
really great study by a child
psychologist in Canada called Crystal
Tomlinson and she found that it was
actually mothers who were perpetuating
harmful gender stereotypes into their
children men the fathers didn't really
care either way but it was often the
mother and then
so
um they did basically a
IAT test I think it is where you're
looking at different images of girls and
boys exhibiting different behaviors and
it basically measures the response of
mothers and fathers to the different
expressions of emotion so a boy crying
for example and it found that the
mothers were
um a lot more disapproving of like
things like boys crying so boys breaking
the gender stereotypes and uh
and it found that surprisingly fathers
didn't seem to have really any sort of
preference either way why do you think
that is why do you think there's a sexed
difference there
I mean it could simply be that mothers
spend more time with children
uh
I honestly don't know I don't I wouldn't
want to comment on something I'm not not
get out over your skis George let's get
some yeah let me give you one let me
give you one let me give you one from me
so there's something called the sexy sun
hypothesis and in it a little bit
already yeah it suggests basically that
what women are trying to do is find
fathers that are going to give them
attractive Sons because attractive sons
are more likely to have kids right I
think that what you see here is maybe an
inbuilt biological mechanism that women
have which is a predisposition to make
their sons attractive to Future women
and they have deep down in understanding
that the more prestigious and
domineering men on average have better
mating outcomes they're more likely like
remember what we are we are
grandchildren optimizing machines that's
what humans are we're not children
optimizing machines we are grandchildren
optimizing machines and once you get two
generations away from you away you go
crack on but I I think that that could
be that could potentially be a big part
of it I loved your breakdown when we
were talking about that conception of
left and right and and how people see it
uh one side is a Mindless cacophony of
anti-male bigotry minimization and
Erasure the other an equally Antiquated
and equally restrictive worldview of
alpha males and pickup Artistry so good
did I say oh good oh yeah you did mate
you would Smith that very well yeah yeah
well I see a lot of stuff in there fan
of your own work
um but yeah I I think so one of the
things one of the things that you're
trying to do is is improve this
conversation and improve the way that
it's communicated given the fact that
you're trying to display these ideas
what have you learned about
the way that it is effective and
ineffective what is missing from the the
communication side of the conversation
when it comes to this topic
uh I just think a really
people just want to live in denial a lot
of the time every single morning for
over three years now I've started my day
the exact same way which is with element
in water element contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium and it is
the best hydration drink that I've ever
found it tastes fantastic it's super
refreshing orange is just the most OP
flavor in the world it's absolutely
phenomenal and it helps to play a
critical role in reducing muscle cramps
and fatigue it regulates your appetite
it optimizes brain health and it helps
curb Cravings they're also the exclusive
hydration partner to Team USA
weightlifting and relied on by tons of
Olympic athletes and everyday High
performers all around the world also
there is a no BS no questions asked
refund policy where you can buy a box
completely risk-free and if you do not
like it for any reason they will give
you a refund during an unlimited
duration and you don't even need to
return the box that's how confident they
are that you'll love it element of
giving away a free sample pack of all
eight flavors with your first box if you
go to the link in the description box
below or drink l mnt.com
MW that's drink
lmnt.com
MW what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
[Music]